welcoming into this video a new video on
middle game strategy yeah and the main
theme of this video will be the other
fight for the center the central squares
that are so important to chess let's
look at this um this game it's been
played in 1900 so quite a long time ago
Paris between Harry Pillsbury back then
the top US player and Georg Marco one of
the top players from Italy maybe hmm I
should look that up maybe
yeah marco is well known for writing
lots of tournament books sermon as well
as being a good player let's see what
happened in this game
we got a Queens gambit declined and
pillsbury went for Bishop g5 back then
this was the most common way to play
they played with Bishop g5 to get this
pin going nowadays many players prefer
the exchange variation only then Bishop
g5 or they go with the Knight f3 and
setups like that but Bishop g5 of course
is of course a normal mainline there
should be seven three even castles
Knight f3 yeah this is some has been
played a thousands of times and nowadays
black almost exclusively place h6 in
this position the rationale being that
gaining this move should be a slide of
achievement
yeah the pawn is very often better on 86
then on h7 it it helps to fight against
back rank mates for example or just to
be ready that a possible attack on h7 is
not that dangerous
yeah the last covariation would name but
still very up-to-date has played a lot
nowadays
although the TMB the Tata cava McKagan
or Bondarev ski variation the line with
three names very often just referred as
to the effort the Tata Cova this is also
very well analyzed nowadays and a good
good way for black to play Marco played
b6 immediately he didn't appreciate that
h6 might be useful move yeah Pennsbury
went Bishop d3 Bishop to b7 and now
white raided note that white traded only
on d5 in a situation where the bishop is
already on b7 yeah quite often it can be
an idea to wait for exactly this moment
here Marco
took on d5 with the pawn this is
possible but I strongly would recommend
to play Knight takes d5 here it is not
an ideal situation for black if you note
that the h7 pawn is still there not on
aged six one reason why this is helpful
it's a structure like the following if
you look at this move like Queen c2 now
just gain the tempo Queen c2 is a useful
move anyway until black needs to react
nevertheless I still think that this was
a better way to play than what he did in
the game and also in this type of
position this also Bishop takes d5 which
is possible it's not ideal with the
pollen h7 but but still he went it takes
and after that white now uses this
opportunity to put the knight on e5 of
course white also could castle play
moves like oopsy 1 but he initiates a
scent
strategy which nowadays is known as the
pillsbury formation Pillsbury had this
type of position a number of times and
scored them yeah excellently well with
it if we return for a moment to this
position here we are already at a
critical juncture because black now with
night bd7 he commits this night to the
square note that only 7 the night is not
attacking much if we look at the
position after f4 it's looking mostly at
squares that's not a square it's looking
mostly at squares that are
well-protected by white the night is not
in any way applying any pressure on
white center if you look at an
alternative c5 here it's a different
matter if you get in c5 now after a
possible F form black might think of
putting the knight on c6 and maybe
straight away now he has pressure on d4
this is a far more challenging way to
play for black it puts pressure on what
Center and makes it a little bit more
difficult for white to continue from
here in the game with the night on d7
blacks counter play is yeah
far less defined how should he get some
counter plane instead of c5 here you had
an additional option that he didn't take
a good alternative here for black was to
play Knight e4
considering the fact that black is
somewhat cramped here he's got less
space it's a good idea to get pieces
traded and 90 formed is a good way to
initiate that yeah white probably now
will aim for this structure takes takes
takes on e7
and now castling yeah this position is
not cleared or black here my Troy Knight
f6 intending c5 you want to attack the
center I could play f6 immediately also
possible something like that it's not
super convincing for white black will
have c5 coming black is not yet in
trouble but he needs to be precise now
in the game we played c5 which is also
good
you want some counter play note that c5
may be intends to take on the form but
there is no big pressure on this pawn
white castles and the next move is one
absolute key move of this game and the
reason why this is a very instructive
example how not to play him as plaque or
let's say as the site a battling such a
center of formation what black now
definitely should do is to go for a
knight move to e4 or maybe 98 to try to
initiate some traits for example if we
look at 94 you can consider to insert h6
not totally clear to me if you should do
that or play 94 immediately 94 this can
be a way to continue after Bishop e7 27
ship takes de 90 727 FD takes e5 we see
a slight problem with this move order
here those Queens opposed to one another
and black here really does not have a
good good move
something like capturing just two leads
to a very bad end game with c5 being
weak and black having no play at all if
everything else fails we go rook c1 this
means that probably the immediate 94 is
slightly tricky the best solution for
black is the following to take on d4
edie and then jump to you for this makes
sure that your pressure is reduced black
some pressure that he's feeling from
from white he black is perfectly okay
yeah what can do I do now he can maybe
take on his heaven if we start with that
green takes and now go from here it's
not like white has just have anything
greater if we look at rook c1 for
example black might even consider to
play f6 yeah f6 can be a good move
getting rid of this maybe ninety form
this is a tricky response after Fe
there's no g5 but still f6 is an
interesting option not necessary though
black can also just play this if he
wants and support his Knight here we
have from the pawn structure point if
you know most symmetrical position Black
has chances because his efore Knight is
also strong he can use this weakness in
the game black decided to do something
else he played the Moose c5 to c4 and
this is really a gross positional error
why the big problem is now you have
released or pressure that black head on
one center there is no central tension
anymore and even the move Knight e4 that
was a serious option earlier is very
problematic now as after those traits
and white capturing here after this
white really is just a pawn up for no
compensation what
94 is not possible
black tried the move a six this is a bit
lame this move but what exactly should
you do one big problem is the knight on
e5 if black takes white has an excellent
position for instance after the F pawn
recapture yeah maybe ninety-seven and
now White has a good choice he can keep
the bishop on the board or can play yeah
okay queen h5 there is g6 but it's
easiest to just keep this piece on the
board and then attack from him if black
now tries to do something on the Queen
side let's say with this then Queen G
form is a huge attack this is one key
problem with the knight on e5 black has
a hard time to take this piece as then
white some initiative together or
supported by the fr we need will unfold
he played a six in order to get in b5
and maybe before relatively speaking it
would move Queen f3 a very strong
continuation white gets the Queen over
to the attack on the King side and he
controls the sensitive before square now
white now as e3 under control there are
three pieces looking at it so Knight e4
now has become completely completely
pointless yeah and here black does not
have f6 because of Queen five check and
wins
yeah but black being unable to play a
nightie form it gets very very difficult
now
he went b5 trying to get some sort of
counter play right now went green a tree
this is a typical move in this position
type the queenís and lining up together
with the bishop on c2 against the
sensitive age 74 they are the first year
the free Liam the first concrete spreads
right now threatens to take on this
happen with a win if we look at nothing
move let's say no he can't even play
before that's it's the same thing
then 97 is the big problem for black if
he now takes with the Queen white is not
content with this this is nice but he
has a much stronger move and a very
typical tactic white can take on edge
savage and this is all based on the fact
that's the Queen on h3 is always
attacking the Queen on d7 after 90s we
just have one the Queen after King edge
eight we have the strong battleship f5
check and again we win the Queen so 90
xt7 here is a very very strong threat
that had been introduced to the position
after Queen f3 if black takes on e5
awesomes that can be considered white
replies with the strong move D takes e5
this is even stronger than taking with
the F pawn very often you automatically
want to take with the F pawn because
this is opened but 94 here is still
pretty tenacious white is better no
doubt but in this concrete case D takes
is even stronger
yeah after 94 we play Knight takes
he takes and rook 81 and here we see a
big problem this is a very very
unfortunate setup and watches twins yeah
black is in huge trouble
he went with g6 that's the relatively
best defense
note that h6 is swiftly punished by a
peace sacrifice on h6 yeah this is just
exceptionally strong nothing black can
do against that yeah he went g6 and now
white obviously has a very very nice
position but how do we continue now note
that black has no counter plane in the
center
he has no pressure on any of those pawns
it's a whole different matter if there
is a pawn on c5 that at any given moment
might take on d4 white now went with f5
directly trying to blow black from the
board and it is very nicely working in
fact like has no defense in this
position he tried before and now why
crashes through he took on g6 H takes 2
6
and now White has two very very nice
ways to win the first way to win is
Knight takes d7 taking here yeah
White is threatening Knight xf6 Oh black
cannot do something like that after the
back it gets very very ugly
so black needs to recapture after Queen
d7 what has Queen h4 we can trade this
line for example is is very very much
better for white and winning but not
like in five or ten moves after I'm
sorry after Knight takes White has a
strong reply you can smash through on g6
after Bishop g6 ever takes track we need
six we see why this is a huge a huge
multiple attack King somewhere and B
should be seven it doesn't matter where
the King goes so very strong and and
quick attack and folding yeah black took
with Sorry Sorry
why didn't take only seven it was strong
but pillsbury played Queen h4 yeah this
move also wins this move also wins I'm
sorry the point is that now after they
capture one c3 white can take on d7 and
this just introduces a big big over note
yeah
Knight takes very simple and after Queen
takes right now can finish things off
with rook takes f6 that's even better
than Bishop takes after Bishop takes and
something like that
it's clear that black is on the ropes
but there does not seem to be a direct
made coming after rook f6 this is really
completely indefensible
if black now would have taken on b2 then
just stroke a f1 intending Bishop takes
g6 this is just a far - yeah this is
just an overwhelming attacking position
black has really no moves to the event
this is of course very easy meeting soon
yeah a5 was played and now look a f1
just using all pieces Bishop takes g6
was already leading to to a quick a
quick defeat for black as well
after TX TX King f7 look everyone check
check Kimi 8 bishops I'm the bishop no
recaptures on a bed I'm sorry Queen h5
white is winning
due to this multiple discoveries that
black cannot defend against this is
however a bit a bit tricky so rook a f1
was played and black has no defense now
we should take g6 as an overwhelming
threat black when Drew a6 and now white
place the finishing touches and took on
g6 threatening mate black mistake by
track trades on f8 and now needs to find
his right continuation why to play it
when Jackie rook takes of a check was
played a very nice finish black has no
big choice he needs to take and then we
have check win 1h a check here Queen f7
mate check and here black has no move
anymore this is a mate checkmate
so he only has a king move that gives up
the Queen like this
and whiter will win with checkmate even
this is indefensible
yeah a very nice win here by Pillsbury
why did he win this game so easily the
main reason is that black did not fight
for the control of the center in a
suitable way the first moment was here
where he could have played the more
active setup c5 and 96 putting pressure
on before the second important moment
comes when he went c4 which is really a
big mistake if black instead plays 94 or
the capture first which is a bit more
precise and then 94 then black does not
have many problems he has ideas on his
own
especially the knight on e4 is well
placed the way it unfolded after c4 and
a six black has no counter play in the
center the knight on e5 is super strong
and can rarely ever be taken so on like
some problems are permanent him and with
very quick and taking moves pillsbury
got an overwhelming position alright I
hope you enjoyed this learning about a
new pawn structure the pillsbury
structure in the center
and it's also a very important lesson
that you must try to initiate counter
play in the center if possible if you
don't it might happen that the
opponent's build-up is so strong that
you are mostly a spectator to what's
happening alright thanks for watching